Les réunions...
...chez Cyprien
Alors, j'ai bossé sur un énorme projet pour ma chaîne YouTube,
C'est très, très, novateur !!
C'est vrai que je sors de ma zone de confort !
Je prends un peu de risques, là !
- Les réunions 3 ?
- Les réunions 3, c'est parti !
Chez Neymar :
Non, je ne vais pas au PSG, voilà !
- Mais qu'est ce que je leur dis !?
- Mais, tu leur donnes un chiffre exorbitant, un truc qu'ils peuvent pas s'offrir, Voilà.
- Genre euh... 250 millions?
*Rires*
Au Qatar :
C'est d'accord !
*racrochement de téléphone*
Oui, belle affaire...
- Oui !
- C'est qui ?
Chez Disney :
J'ai pensé pour le prochain Star Wars, c'est l'histoire de la princesse Leia qui va aller récupérer...
- Ah ouais, mais non, la princesse Leia, on peut pas... L'actrice est morte.
- Non mais c'est pas grave ça ! On la fait en 3D !
- Ah bon ?
- Bah oui, on fait un hologramme !
- Ah, c'est possible, ça ?
- Bah, bien sûr que c'est possible !
Regarde, moi, je suis en hologramme depuis le début !
*Son stylé du futur*
- Mais non !
Non, je déconne, moi aussi je suis en hologramme depuis le début, en fait.
*Son*
- Bah, mais, mais nan !
Chez Desigual® :
Alors, notre nouveau modèle, bon appétit, -merci là tu peux voir au niveau des coutures y'a un travail...
- Petite tomate basilic ? Ho, écoute, pourquoi pas, hein ?
*Ils s'amusent !*
- Oh non !
- La nouvelle collection !
Chez Supreme® :
Vous voyez, ce T-Shirt, vous donnez combien ?
- Je sais pas, 5€ ?
- Bah oui, pas plus, hein ?
Et là ?
*En cœur*
- 40€ !
- Pas mal !
- Et oui !
Chez Desigual® :
-J'arrive
- Oh, le patron qui arrive ! Oh là là !
- J'adore !
*Ils deviennent fous !*
Chez OCS :
C'est génial, toutes les séries qu'on a !
- Bah, Game of Thrones !
- Oui, et puis !
- The Walking Dead !
- Et oui et puis euh...
Chez Facebook® :
Bon, les mecs,
- 'Faut mettre le paquet sur la vidéo et...
Oooooooh !!!
Qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ?
Ah !!!!
Oh non ! Y'en a partout !
Chez Hand Spinner® :
Mais à quoi ça sert exactement ?
- Ça tourne...
- Mais ça marchera jam...
Chez Netflix® :
- Il y a que des séries de super-héros quoi !
- Les gens, ils vont s'lasser !
T'sais ce qu'il faut faire, il faut parler au patron !
- C'est ça, dès qu'il arrive, on lui dit, c'est fini les super-héros !
- On lui dit, c'est terminé !
- J'ai plein d'idées de séries !
- Ahhh...
Chez Hand Spinner® :
- J'te l'avais dit, c'est l'idée du siècle !
- OH LES GARS C'EST LA M*RDE !!
ON N'EN VEND PLUS !
- MAIS NAN !
- Mais on s'en fout, on est déjà super riches !
*Musique*
Chez Instagram® :
- On pourrait faire un petit peu comme sur Snapchat
C'est-à-dire des photos et des vidéos
Uniquement disponibles 24 heures
- Et bah, c'est super, on fait comme Snapchat !
- Oui, mais par contre, pour les filtres on s'était dit qu'on pourrait changer la donne, on a pris...
- ON FAIT TOUT COMME SNAPCHAT ! C'est bon.
- D'accord, ou alors le nom, parce que Story, c'est vraiment comme Snapchat...
- ON FAIT TOUT COMME SNAPCHAT !
Chez Snapchat® :
- Alors petite nouveauté chez Snapchat,
-  Hop, voilà , le filtre directement sur le visage...
- Oooooh !
Super !
- Oh !
C'est génial !
- Et comment ça s'enlève ?
- Ah je sais pas, j'ai pas pensé à ça...
Aaaah !!!
Chez Escape Game :
Eh ben on a bien bossé, hein ?
- Bravo !
Allez à la prochaine, hein ?
Okay, il nous faut une clé !
- Il y a un cadenas sous la table !
- J'ai le code !
Chez PlayStation :
Alors, c'est comment ?
- On prend ça pour un oui ?
- Bruh !
C'est génial !
Vraiment, meilleure expérience de ma vie !
Chez TF1® :
- Oh Denis ! Venez, venez !
- Regardez, c'est juste ici !
- Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
- Il s'est coincé la tête dans un attaché-case, c'est affreux !
- Oh !
Oooooh...
Oh, merde !
- Ah ça, là !
- On y était presque !
- Ah !
Chez Pokémon GO :
J'ai le plaisir de vous annoncer le premier jeu Pokémon sur mobile,
Pokémon GO !
- Pika !
- Ooooooh !!!!
- Des millions d'utilisateurs...
*brouhaha incompréhensible*
Bon allez, hein !
C'était marrant cinq minutes ce jeu, mais...
- Mais non, mais il y a une mise à jour qui vient de sortir !
Chez Starbucks® :
Attendez mais vous savez pas écrire le prénom "Etienne" !?
- Non mais je suis désolé, j'y arrive pas !
- Bienvenue chez Starbucks !
Comment vous écrivez Gérard ?
- Euh J, F... A!
- C'est parfait ! Directeur des ventes !
Chez Pokémon GO :
Il y a une quoi ?
- Une mise à jour !
- Ah ouais... J'avais compris mieux.
- Pikachuu !!
- Mais casse-toi, toi ! P*tain...
Chez Instagram® :
Il y a une énorme star qui va nous rendre visite aujourd'hui chez Instagram !
- Mais non !
Mais si !
Salut, je suis Justin Bieber !
Le célèbre chanteur de musique populaire.
J'organise un concours pour mes plus grands fans !
Vous voulez gagner des iPhone ?
Il suffit d'appeler ce numéro, et de donner 12 codes.
Il y a pas d'arnaque, je suis Justin Bieber.
Salut, je m'appelle Natoo !
Tu veux gagner des iPhone ?
*Ils sont super heureux !*
- Mais c'est incroyable !
- Tellement sympa !
- Elle est comment, Selena Gomez en vrai ? Hé, Natoo !
Chez Twitter® :
Il y a une taupe de chez Snapchat chez nous !
- Bah en tout cas, c'est pas moi.
- Moi non plus !
- Bwaaaah !!!
À la SNCF :
On est à l'heure !
Bah les gens disent qu'à la SNCF on est toujours en retard !
Vous êtes bien venus en train ?
- Bon, j'avoue, je suis venu en Uber...
- Et moi, je suis toujours chez moi, je suis en hologramme...
- Oh, mais non !
- Bon j'avoue, moi aussi, je suis un hologramme depuis le début.
- Mais nan !
Chez les mecs qui font les drones :
Ah, ouais alors.. Oula. Ah ah..
- Mais du coup il est cassé, là !
- Et les clients, ils s'en rachètent un deuxième !
- Oh, là là !
À la Halle aux chaussures :
Peut-être qu'on pourrait vendre des chaussettes !
*Ils sont vraiment énervés !*
- Mais il est fou !
- Mais tu veux couler la boîte, Denis ?!
Chez les internautes :
Bon déjà, à la Halle Aux Chaussures, ils vendent aussi des chaussettes !
Chez Apple® :
Le prix de l'iPhone 10 :
- 899€ !
- Plus !
- 950€ !
- C'est plus !
- C'est moins de 1000€ ?
- C'est plus.
- C'est plus que notre salaire ?
- C'est plus !
- MAIS NON !?
Au Qatar :
1329€ ?
- Ouais mais sans dec', c'est beaucoup trop cher !
- On est pas des pigeons !
- Les gens sont fous, hein ?
À la Maison Blanche :
Trump: Bon, il a dit quoi, l'autre chinois, là ?
Il est pas chinois, il est coréen, il nous menace,
- OK, vous avez raison, je vais l'exploser.
- NON NON NON !!
À Pyongyang :
OK, on lui envoie 100 missiles dans la gueule !
- 100 missiles ?
- Non non, on a pas 100 missiles... On en a 4, 5.
- 2, 3.
- 2, 3, 2, 3!
- Max !
À la Maison Blanche :
- Qu'est ce qu'y a ? Je suis président, je fais ce que je veux !
- Oui mais on n'explose pas les ge- NON NON !!
À Pyongyang :
Et bah, on envoie 2, 3 missiles sur les États-Unis !
- Sur les Éta- Ah non, c'est trop loin, les États-Unis...
- En général, c'est le Japon, mais euh...
- Souvent, ça tombe dans l'eau.
Okay, bon, bah on envoie les missiles dans l'eau, ALLEZ c'est parti ils vont se chier dessus !
À la Maison Blanche :
Ils nous ont envoyé un missile !
- Mais c'est tombé dans l'eau, hein !
- Oui, ils nous visaient pas ! C'était le Japon, hein.
- D'accord, mais je vais quand même leur EXPLOSER LA GUE*LE !
- J'ai inversé les fils avec la lumière...
- Bien joué !
- Je vais le tweeter !
- Ah ! Bien joué !
Eh ! N'éteins pas la lumière en partant !
Ah, ah, ah !
Ah, ça consomme, cette ampoule, hein ?
*Explosion*
Et n'oublie pas,
Ah ! -Bonne-toi !
Clique juste ici pour découvrir les scènes coupées, et le bêtisier.
Tu vas voir, c'est très drôle, je t'ai réservé quelques petites surprises ! #Jambon
ST : ARMAND JANKOWIAK Enoha Sulinger
SuperMarioClub
Élie Santiago-Ladouceur
Les Masquet fr
Lison M